نشره ايجاز من تلي ابيب اهلا بكم كتائب
القسام تقول انها دمرت دبابات واليات
عسكريه اسرائيليه في حي الزيتون وشمال غرب
غزه وتنشر صورا لهجوم على اليات اسرائيليه
متوغلا في محاور عده من القطاع والجيش
الاسرائيلي يعلن مقتل ضابط كبير وجرحى
ثلاثه ضباط في معارك غزه واصابه مجنده على
الحدود
المصريه
961 شهيدا في الغارات الاسرائيليه المط
صله على غزه وزاره الصحه في القطاع تحذر
من كارثه بعد توقف المولد الرئيسي في
المستشفى الاندونيسي واليونيسيف تدعو الى
وقف اطلاق نار انساني فورا وادخال
المساعدات الانسانيه الى غزه دون
قيود شهداء وجرحى في قصف اسرائيلي بقنابل
الفسفور الابيض على محيط مدرسه للاونروا
غربيه غزه سلطات غزه تقول ان كميه القنابل
الملقات تتجاوز 25 الفقر في حين طالبت
العفو الدوليه بتحقيق دولي في الانتهاكات
الاسرائيليه للقانون الدولي الانساني اما
المرصد الاورو متوسطي فقد قال ان اسرائيل
اسقطت ما يعادل قنبلتين نوويتين على
غزه وفي الضفه الغربيه ثلاثه شهداء وعده
جرحى في هجمات اسرائيليه على رام الله
والبير وق القيه ارتفاع عدد الشهداء في
الضفه الى
132 منذ السابق من اكتوبر ووسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه تؤكد مقتل اسرائيلي في اطلاق
نار في بيت ليد بالضفه الغربيه الى
اللقاء